[Music]
for this next segment um I have a pretty
cool um pretty cool
gift my friend Dr Uma Naidu she is I'm
gonna read this she's a nutritional
psychiatrist a Harvard trained
psychiatrist that focuses on the impact
of food and mental and emotional health
okay um she founded directed the first
hospital-based nutritional Psychiatry
service in the US she's a director of
nutritional and lifestyle Psychiatry at
gen mass at Massachusetts General
Hospital a very famous hospital and
she's also on the faculty at Harvard
Medical School here's her expertise her
expertise is the mechanics of how what
we eat impacts our physical and
psychological health and really our
emotional health if you're if I get
really great about it but for the sake
of your souls we didn't get super nerdy
we didn't go down all the mechanistic
convers like like just super nerdy
here's what we talk about what should
you actually eat are you sick of it you
got to be raw vegan I was I told her
during the interview I was scrolling the
day and someone was like oatmeal will
kill you oh my gosh you got to eat all
meat and be like what are we
doing as my friend Dr Norton says we
step over $1100 bills to pick up nickels
when it comes to nutrition and so
finally not finally I've had several
guests on the show she is yet another
great guest talk about what are we
supposed to
eat she's got a brand new book out calm
your mind with food calm your mind with
food and it's it's a discussion of the
connection between anxiety and what we
eat I mentioned it briefly in my book um
this this connection between what we we
eat and how our body
responds ah so much here so in the space
of a
call Dr Naidu and I unpack some things
well actually she unpacks it I asked her
some questions and she just runs with it
because she's brilliant
so after uh Thanksgiving and Christmas
where if you're like me you got off the
rails Dr naid is here to help taking you
into the new season I'm G to tell you
spoiler alert you're G to go that's
really and the answer is yes we've made
things way way way too complicated
here's my conversation with Dr Uma
Naidu it was good to talk to you again
um man I've done a million uh Instagram
lives and I've not had the the feedback
that I got from our last conversation so
I'm glad that you are able to join me on
the show that's so
fantastic thank you I appreciate that
you have a great audience and uh clearly
the stuff that we talk about which is
awesome I don't know I don't know
anybody who is not just thrown their
hands up and said I quit when it comes
to was I scrolling the other night on
Instagram which I'm not supposed to do
but I was and I ran across one goofball
saying oatmeal will be the death of you
it's the worst thing you can put in your
body um somebody else saying that
protein is overrated you shouldn't have
so much protein somebody else say
it's just Madness and when you actually
Madness so I
feel let me say it like this I I feel
one of the greatest honors of my life is
I have friends like you in spaces that
live in this data and I'm able to pick
up a phone and say hey walk me through
this real quick but
99.999% of the US population doesn't
have access to people like you right
right and
so what happened what happened with our
food conversation that got so sideways
that there's people on one side saying
eggs are bad and somebody over here is
saying if you eat meat you're G to all
be dead and somebody else saying you
know oatmeal will kill you and then
somebody else saying no you got to eat
protein or your body doesn't work right
what are ah what are we supposed to do
how did this happen it's yeah well I
think it happened because well there's
there's definitely been an exp explosion
I'm sure you'll agree with everything
that went online over Co right and prior
to that we were already a mixed Nation
Eat This Not That you know seeing things
as just categories of food versus what
about just moving from the standard
American diet called sad for a reason to
just a Whole Foods diet as best we can
it's not perfect but as many Whole Foods
I also feel like uh people make these
statements for um to enhance their
followers and to enhance Eng engagement
and all this trickery which hey you know
what you want to build your Instagram
following you go do you but provide the
public with well vetted information for
example oatmeal oatmeal can be
complicated a JN because sometimes the
prepackaged oatmeal can be loaded with
lots of sugar and stuff that we don't
really need a version of oatmeal can be
healthier and a good grain for you to
eat but should you be eating it every
single day maybe not because
continuous glucose monitoring studies
and research you show that it does
actually hit your metabolic Health it's
not always the healthiest food in the
way that it's claimed to be and the way
it's marketed now does that mean it's
evil no that means have your oatmeal
make it in a healthy way you know add in
a a good source of milk or whatever
you're doing be mindful of your toppings
and don't have it for every single day
mix it up with Cher pudding in eggs and
all sorts of things but the conversation
has gotten very toxic and I find it uh
I'm often dealing with the aftermath of
people coming and saying well I I was
told I should never eat a a a bean and
someone else saying I have to go
plant-based because I'm hearing if I eat
meat it's going to kill me so it's it's
a lot of confusion out there and hard to
sort through you just said it sorry for
interrupting you just said it something
that I want everyone to hear and
um I've become close friends with
several folks in the nutritional space
who have degrees they have pedigree here
and they know what they're talking about
and behind closed doors when I ask him
like Hey why do you keep why do you keep
going after people it's what you just
said because they end up in the hospital
they end up with completely deranged
metabolic systems they they end up with
completely deranged um um I don't want
to get too nerdy but their body start
falling apart and they're just trying
kudos to you for say here's actual data
here's like and you're not just somebody
you're not just like a nerd like me who
sits in a room and writes books you also
see patience you also build programs
that have efficacy to them like you're
not just an influencer trying to get a
following it sounds like you are at the
at the end receiving line in a hospital
with these folks and you're tired of
seeing hurting people and so if we can
move Upstream so I'm just so grateful
thank you it all lands on this I want
you're going to save us all right now
okay and I know I don't I don't give any
spoiler alerts uh spoilers in your book
I want everyone to pick up calm your
mind with food so picture in your mind a
single mom with three kids and she's
just been buying a bag of of offbrand
Cheerios and that's what her kids have
for breakfast and she gives them skim
milk because she heard that full fat
milk's bad for him or the Over The Road
Trucker who is puts on five or 10 pounds
every year just wants to be a little
more present father he's got a little
more energy wants to slowly begin to to
to give his kids a picture what would
you just outline as big
picture what should they
eat some basic principles basic
principles go yes and go towards
actually have six pillars of nutritional
Psychiatry which I outlined in my first
book and and some of the pillars are the
following eat the whole food and SK the
processed version of it so what do I
mean by that eat an orange skip the
stought orange juice which has all the
fiber removed and added sugars which you
don't need but if you eat the orange it
has all the micronutrients you need it
is fresh delicious and has vitamins as
well the more times we can keep that
mind that principle in mind the better
you can have frozen broccoli you can get
broccoli in the uh fresh produce section
or cauliflower or you can have the
highly processed version that's added to
a nugget or um some kind of you know
trickery that the food company has come
up with to sell that broccoli to as a
healthy product unfortunately even if
the broccoli is okay it's loaded with a
lot of stuff that your body doesn't need
and what I'm referring to are the
colorance of Dy of food stabilizers Etc
that you don't need and that's what goes
into processed foods and research has
shown in animals that when we consume
things like thickeners called CMC
carboxy meal cellulose from uh foods
that are thickened with it for example
that it is damaging and disruptive to
the gut microbiome in animal studies and
in fact leads to short lower production
of short chain fatty acids something
that we want our gut microbes to be
helping us produce that's healthy for us
that that fend off inflammation and
other discomfort in the gut so we know
this and what we want to be doing is
just going as much as possible for um
for for Whole Foods when we can
difficult to avoid processed food but
what you choose makes a difference
um another thing is lean into the the
the leafy greens because wherever you
can get your B vitamins think brain B
vitamins because many of the B vitamins
if not all of them are involved in brain
health vitamin B12 from different animal
proteins or nutritional yeast vitamin B9
from leafy greens folate low folate is
associated with the low mood so that's a
good one for you so I say add in those
leafy greens and have your nutritional
Psychiatry plate mostly loaded with
colorful vegetables for the fiber the
micronutrients that you're going to get
and and all the things that your body
needs then choose your clean protein you
may want a nice piece of beef you may
want a piece of tofu whatever your
dietary preference is make sure it's the
best version that you can get that's
accessible to you then add in your
healthy fats and a smaller portion of
say a whole grain like kinma or whatever
it is that you prefer so in other words
you're not you don't have a pile of
kinma you have a small serving ofid but
you're really filling your plate with
satiating vegetables which are complex
they are carbohydrate but complex they
break down more slowly this is a simple
thing if we think about it we can adjust
in every single plate that we eat or
what we cook um so it's going back to
those principles and then add in spices
and herbs because they're rich in
antioxidant and anti-inflammatory
properties they're pretty much calorie
free they're saltree and sugarfree if
you just buy a spice you know from the
from the supermarket and you can flavor
up your food to make them make whatever
you're eating super delicious so those
are just some jumping off points for
people to try and don't forget water
hydration is extremely important and
dehydration worsens depression and makes
people anxious
so so tell me if I if I'm smiling
because um I had a buddy about a decade
ago he since passed away but about a
decade ago he said the Arc of nutrition
and Physiology
exercise is heading towards something
that is going to be very challenging to
package and sell and I said what do you
mean by that and it
continues like how do you get in great
physical shape well walk most of the
time or do some zone two and have a
Sprint day and lift weights several
times a week Tada and as my buddy Dr
Norton says people often trip over $100
bills to pick up nickels we want it to
be so complex and similarly we have so
many fat diets and so much this and so
much this and so much this and what
you're saying is hey eat whole real
foods the way nature invented them right
and get make sure you get enough fiber
and and good vegetables and make sure
you get good proteins and have a little
fun along the
way it can't be that easy but just is
it so I think I think this is this is
where it gets hard it gets hard with the
the different type of messaging that's
out there like you mentioned the oatmeal
issue yeah and it also gets difficult
because I I fundamentally do believe
people know what healthier foods are but
it's inconvenient they're often stressed
and in a rush to get food on the table
make sure that the family is fed make
sure that you know um that there are
choices that that Everyone likes and I
think unfortunately we get you know we
we start to eat processed food and our
brain gets stct into liking it because
the processed foods are engineered to be
hyper palatable to tap our Cravings if
you've ever ordered french fries at a
fast food drive-thru you're often
upsized and when you're upsized you eat
the whole bag and then the next day
you're like H maybe I want some more um
you're a healthy guy maybe that's not
happen to but it happens to a lot I
would have I would have I would have
french fries every day yes multiple
times they're so they're so good and and
and here and here's the thing uh they
are delicious but they in a fast food
restaurant they actually often have
added sugar that you don't taste but
they've been engineered to be so tasty
and yummy that we want more and our
brain then once it again so these are
these are the things that that we're
working against and what we what I'm
saying is that it there's it's much more
nuanced than what I'm sharing right now
and the nuances are in the book you know
what are the different spices you want
to incorporate for anxiety what the
different herbs that are possible which
tees are best but for basic principles
it it's not that's so easy it's more
that we've almost lost our way and
people have this this messaging which
gives them more confusing information
and when they have just a plate of food
in front of them they think it can't be
this you know and I feel like part of it
is also making that habit change because
we often choose foods out of convenience
and it's harder to make those homecooked
meals and do the shopping and prepare
because we're all so busy but research
has even shown that you know when we
prepare our meals at home and we eat
more meals at home we lose weight and we
consume pure calories so this is helpful
information for us to know yeah that's
incredible well thank you so so much for
joining us um all the way from are you
in Boston now
now I'm actually in New York today
because I had an event here so very cool
well thank you for making time for us
and for audience and um we will link to
your book and um I wish you the absolute
best um just some quick advice to you
during your book um your book launch
week make sure you eat lots of leafy
green vegetables and clean I'm just
kidding hey I'm really really grateful
for you you're so you're so generous
with your time but I wish you the
absolute best sell a million cop thank
you thank you
doc